es particularmente significativo hablar
en persona vernos a los ojos porque el
liderazgo a través de esta crisis ha
inspirado al pueblo ucraniano tanto como
usted señor presidente el pueblo
estadounidense y el resto del mundo
Ese es su primer viaje fuera de Ucrania
desde febrero
llega a medida que el presidente Putin
escara los ataques brutales
que hacen blanco infraestructura crucial
y hacia la vida difícil no solamente
para los ucranianos adultos sino para
los niños los jóvenes los orfanatos las
escuelas Simplemente no están
funcionando Y esto es absurdo como hemos
oído a medida que hemos avanzado el
próximo año es importante para el pueblo
estadounidense y para el mundo
escucharlo directamente usted señor
presidente escuchar la lucha y la
necesidad de seguir Unidos
en todo 2023
de la invasión brutal de Ucrania 300
días desde que Putin lanzó una guerra y
no provocada y justificada un asalto
completo sobre el pueblo libre de
Ucrania 300 días de que el pueblo
ucraniano le estaba mostrando el mundo y
a Rusia
su columna vertebral su amor por el país
y su determinación irrompible insisto en
la determinación irrompible de elegir su
propio camino
al pueblo ucraniano le digo a todos
ustedes han demostrado
su fortaleza ante esta agresión frente
al apetito imperialista de los
autócratas que creen equivocadamente
que podrían
hacer algo bien sin poder hacerlo
realmente
pero usted ha estado ahí solo y a la vez
ha tenido un gran apoyo usted nunca
estará realmente solo los ucranianos no
estarán solos la de Ucrania fue
amenazada del pueblo estadounidense
generaciones estadounidenses como la
generación estadounidenses en el pasado
no dudaron en apoyar y el apoyo viene de
todo el país estadounidenses de todas
partes republicanos demócratas han
entregado recursos
para responder de manera unida resonante
y brindar
un apoyo inequívoco irrompible Porque
entendemos en nuestro interior que la
lucha ucraniana es parte de algo mucho
más grande el pueblo estadounidense sabe
que si estamos quietos frente a tantos
graves ataques contra la democracia y la
libertad y contra principios como la
integridad territorial y la soberanía
del mundo seguramente enfrentará
consecuencias peores como dije cuando
Putin llevó sus tanques a Ucrania en
febrero
el pueblo estadounidense está preparado
para
defenderse para defender la libertad y
eso es Quiénes somos estadounidenses Y
eso es exactamente lo que hemos hecho
antes de que iniciara la invasión antes
de que Putin amenazara Ucrania
aumentando su fuerza militar Tratamos de
asegurarnos que Ucrania pudiera
defenderse incluso antes de que cruzara
la frontera
brindamos un flujo de armas defensivas
continuo incluyendo misiles artillería
munición y mucho más
y no lo hemos hecho solos desde el
principio de los Estados Unidos
reunieron a sus aliados y a sus socios
de todo el mundo
para mantenerse fuertes al lado de
Ucrania
y hago énfasis
sanciones sin precedentes para controlar
a Rusia Parece ser que sea más difícil
para ellos llevar a cabo esta guerra
brutal
más de 50 naciones se han comprometido
han comprometido alrededor de 200
tanques y vehículos armados más de 800
sistemas de artillería más de 2 millones
de rondas de munición de artillería
y más de 15 más de 50
superficies de lanzamiento móvil de
misiles y también hablo de sistemas de
defensa aérea todo para fortalecer
Ucrania juntos hemos prohibido miles de
millones de dólares en respaldo
financiero directo para asegurarnos de
que el gobierno ucraniano pudiera seguir
brindando servicios vitales como Salud
Educación
personas de emergencia esto incluye
otros dos mil millones de dólares
de respaldo directo del presupuesto por
parte
estadounidenses que el Banco Mundial
distribuyó a inicios de esta semana
brindamos asistencia humanitaria para
millones de ucranianos que han sido
forzados sus hogares por la guerra
humana inhumana y brutal de Putin
esas personas han abierto sus corazones
en Europa para ayudar a los ucranianos
en necesidad de Estados Unidos incluso
dado la bienvenida a miles de ucranianos
que buscan Refugio desde marzo 2022
incluyendo como parte de la iniciativa
United
y Hoy
está comprometiendo más de 374 millones
de dólares
para brindar ayuda humanitaria a Ucrania
esto brindará comida agua a más de 1.5
millones de estado de ucranianos acceso
a salud acceso a agua potable y acceso
al calor durante el invierno para más de
2.5 millones de ucranianos Estados
Unidos y sus aliados y socios en todo el
mundo han entregado una gran cantidad de
medidas de asistencia a una velocidad
histórica y ha sido crítico para
impulsar el éxito creen hasta el momento
Ucrania ha ganado la ha ganado la
batalla de gerson ha ganado la batalla
de
Ucrania ha desafiado las expectativas de
Rusia
en cada momento
presidente usted ha dejado Claro
que está abierto voy a poner de esa
manera él no está abierto pero ustedes
está abierto va a buscar la paz ustedes
está abierto a buscar una paz justa
también sabemos que Putin no tiene
ninguna intención ninguna intención de
detener esta guerra cruel y los Estados
Unidos están comprometidos para
asegurarse que el pueblo ucraniano siga
defendiendo a su país en contra de las
agresiones rusas tanto como tome quiero
agradecerle a los miembros del Congreso
por su amplio apoyo y parte de esta
Ucrania espero firmar
el acta
que incluye 45 mil millones de dólares
45 mil millones de fondos adicionales
pero Ucrania También firmaré el acta de
defensa nacional y autorización que
facilitará las autorizaciones a las
autoridades del departamento de defensa
Buscar materiales de defensa y munición
para Ucrania
otras materiales para fortalecer nuestra
seguridad nacional y hoy estoy
anunciando
la próxima
1.85 mil millones de dólares
de asistencia de seguridad que incluyen
transferencias directas de equipo y
Ucrania necesita tanto como contratos
para suministrar munición a Ucrania que
necesitarán en los próximos meses para
su artillería sus tanques y sus
lanzacohetes críticamente en edición con
estas nuevas capacidades como las
municiones de precisión aérea el paquete
incluirá una batería de misiles
para la cual entrenaremos a las fuerzas
ucranianas como un esfuerzo en curso
para fortalecer la defensa aérea de
Ucrania esto podría tomar algo de tiempo
para completar el entrenamiento
necesario pero la batería será otro
activo crítico para Ucrania a medida que
se defiende de la agresión rusa
todo Unido
la asistencia de seguridad que lanzamos
hoy llega hasta Dos punto dos mil
millones de dólares en respaldo para el
pueblo ucraniano
Debería ser claro lo que Rusia está
haciendo
es un ataque
a la infraestructura crítica ucraniana a
propósito destruyendo instalaciones que
le brindan luz y calor al oro durante la
parte más oscura y fría del año Rusia
está utilizando el invierno como un arma
congelando a las personas matándolas de
hambre aislándolas
es el ejemplo más reciente de la
atrocidad de la fuerzas rusas en contra
de civiles ucranianos inocentes civiles
sus familias niños
socios y aliados estamos trabajando para
brindar asistencia Ucrania para que
hagan reparaciones de emergencia
plantas de transmisión de energía
también como fortaleciendo el resto de
la red eléctrica a pesar de los ataques
rusos También estamos trabajando para
hacer que Rusia sea responsable
incluyendo esfuerzos en el congreso que
harán que sea más fácil Buscar justicia
por los crímenes de guerra rusos en
Ucrania quiero cerrar con esto Esta
noche
es la cuarta noche de hanuka un momento
en el que el pueblo judío en todo el
mundo
presidente de las familias entre ellos
honran El Milagro atemporal y una
pequeña banda de guerreros que estaban
luchando por sus valores y por su
libertad en contra de una enemigo mucho
mayor y como soportaron y como superaron
esta situación como la llama de la fe
que solamente tenía suficiente llama
para un día
brillo por ocho una historia de
resiliencia que nos Recuerda que los
días más fríos del año
en estos días la luz Siempre
prevalecerá sobre la oscuridad y la
esperanza superará a la desesperación y
ahí el espíritu bueno es inconquistable
a medida que haya buenas personas
dispuestas a hacer lo correcto este año
ha traído un sufrimiento innecesario al
pueblo ucraniano pero quiero que usted
sepa presidente quiero que usted sepa
que todo el pueblo de Ucrania también
debe saberlo
el pueblo estadounidense estará con
ustedes que en cada paso y nos
quedaremos de su lado estaremos con
ustedes tanto tiempo como sea necesario
lo que ustedes están haciendo lo que
ustedes han logrado no importa solo para
Ucrania sino para todo el mundo y juntos
no tengo ninguna duda de que mantenemos
la llamada de la libertad viva y la luz
prevalecerá sobre la oscuridad Muchas
gracias por estar aquí Señor Presidente
estamos del lado suyo
Muchas gracias
querido señor presidente por favor
utilice su equipo de nuevo Señor
Presidente presidente biden
audiencia periodistas damas y caballeros
vengo aquí hoy a los Estados Unidos
a entregar las palabras de
agradecimiento al pueblo estadounidense
gente que ha hecho tanto por Ucrania
estoy muy agradecido por todo esto Esta
visita de los Estados Unidos se ha
convertido
en algo histórico Para nuestras
relaciones con los Estados Unidos y los
líderes estadounidenses los últimos 30
días de esta guerra hemos empezado
a una nueva etapa de nuestras relaciones
con los Estados Unidos nos hemos
convertido
en verdaderos socios verdaderos aliados
me alegra mucho esto y sentí esta
sensación durante
mis encuentros de hoy durante todas
nuestras charlas de nuevo quiero
agradecerle al señor presidente el
presidente biden por su increíble
respaldo
mucho
más importante también el respaldo de la
coalición internacional para fortalecer
la ley internacional estoy muy
agradecido con el presidente Byron
por sus esfuerzos personales por los
pasos que ha dado para unir a estos
socios
Incluso en el sur global cuando todos
los países del Mundo
asumen una posición
y se enfocan en la cooperación y en el
entendimiento
algo Bastante Útil para todos los países
para Ucrania para Estados Unidos yo de
verdad Quiero agradecer también al
congreso
y tengo la esperanza de buenas reuniones
con los miembros Y obtener su respaldo
Esta es la visita
que espero hoy hoy encontrarme con el
congreso el tema principal
durante mi discusión de hoy es
fortalecer a Ucrania el próximo año
de aquí en adelante para luchar por
nuestra libertad y nuestra independencia
tengo buenas noticias
el presidente biden anunció un nuevo
paquete de respaldo la defensa de
alrededor de dos mil millones de dólares
y el elemento más fuerte
es el sistema de baterías algo que
fortalecerá nuestras defensas aéreas de
manera significativa Este es un paso muy
importante para crear y asegurar el
espacio aéreo ucraniano es la única
manera en la que podremos impedir que
este país terrorista haga ataques
terroristas
en contra energético nuestro pueblo
nuestra infraestructura
Tuvimos una negociación unas discusiones
bastante buenas sobre nuestros pasos
estratégicos algo que discutimos con el
presidente lo que esperamos el próximo
año
para lo que nos estamos preparando esto
es muy importante para todos los
ucranianos y tengo la gran esperanza de
nuevo gracias señor presidente por estos
45 mil millones porque es una asistencia
muy importante y espero que el congreso
vaya a probar esta asistencia financiera
para nuestro país
y muchas gracias de verdad por este
respaldo cada dólar de esta inversión
aparte de Estados Unidos
a fortalecer la seguridad global y yo sé
que el liderazgo estadounidense será
fuerte
jugará un rol importante en la
perspectiva global y en los Estados
Unidos nos ayudarán a defender nuestros
valores y independencias sin importar
los cambios en el congreso yo creo que
habrá
un respaldo bipartidista y bicameral
dice que todos trabajan
reuniones hoy discutimos temas
de
energía
la destrucción
infraestructura
debemos sobrevivir este invierno debemos
proteger a nuestro pueblo
necesitamos ser muy específicos en esta
área Este es un tema clave el
humanitario para nosotros es la
supervivencia
estamos discutiendo sanciones
y presión legal sobre este país
terrorista Rusia Rusia debe
hacerse responsable por cada cosa que
haga en contra nuestra en contra de
nuestro pueblo en contra de toda Europa
y el resto del mundo libre y es muy
importante que
tengamos una fórmula para la paz
nosotros ofrecemos unos pasos muy
específicos dijimos qué puede hacer
Estados Unidos para ayudarnos a
implementarlo proponemos una fórmula
global para la paz una Cumbre y estoy
agradecido por que nuestras contrapartes
estadounidenses no se entienden y
entiende Lo importante que es seguir
mantener el curso
para trabajar en la integridad del país
y el estado de derecho internacional
también necesitaremos Tan pronto como
nuestras capacidades de defensa se han
fortalecidas en los próximos meses no
quiero discutirlo en detalle en estos
momentos
creo que ustedes entenderán por qué pero
estoy muy agradecido con el presidente
biden
gracias por su atención a tantos temas
Gloria